i got a chance to see you walk the fire
a little bit
uh privately and publicly
uh this year in january i gotta ask you
about that
so there's like generic conversations
about sort of cancel culture and all
those kinds of things but as a human
being this to me is fascinating
sort of there's the uh n word highlight
video there's the
criticism of the different guests
whatever the side is on the covid
pandemic
and you
i mean there's a mass amount of attack
on you
outside of being a public persona
outside of being a
comedian podcaster you're you're also a
human being so how did you survive that
how did you sort of uh walk through that
fire because you seem to do it with
grace
i use mushrooms
[Laughter]
that was one way i did it yeah yeah
really what's your as andrew hubert
would say what was your protocol uh i
took
it was probably less than a gram every
day every day yeah
and uh
[Laughter]
i did a lot of like really hard working
out
but also
i mean
there's a great benefit to going through
anything difficult and if you're aware
like in advance and why enduring
like anything that's going to happen
that's very difficult
and troubling
the the great benefit is it gives you an
opportunity to grow gives you an
opportunity to express yourself under
pressure
to show your character to show you truly
are
and
it gives you an opportunity to see how
you handle a very difficult situation it
also
was uh fascinating as a person that's
involved in media
right because what we're doing right now
is media even though
you know it seems like podcasts seem
like we're just having a conversation
right and they are we in in that sense
it's kind of the purest form of media
because what you're doing is you're
you're you're doing it without any
fanfare you're doing it without any
there's no
executives looming over your head or
network or big meetings about ratings or
any of that stuff but it is media but
what i got to see is the wiring under
the machine
of how the rest of media
would try to take me out and you know
like when cnn would be just be playing
things over and over and back and forth
it was wild to watch what was also wild
to watch was people's responses
because
i gained two million subscribers
during that time like the podcast never
got bigger it just kept kept growing and
growing it had never been bigger than it
had been like at the end of all of it
it just made it bigger
and you know
ultimately
when
if you've [ __ ] up in the past or made
mistakes or done something wrong
that gives you an opportunity to discuss
those things and to say to apologize if
you feel the need to apologize
and also to just address it and so
people
under that kind of pressure they get
it's an opportunity for them to
understand how you think about things
honestly how you actually honestly think
about things and there's no more honesty
that you get out of a person than when
that person is under extreme duress
you know so i think in that sense
i mean it's horrible to say that it's a
benefit that it's a good thing that it
happened but it was a benefit can you
see how it can break a person yes i've
gotten the chance to experience small
small attacks here and there yeah ones
that get to the core of things like even
just talking to uh
about russia and ukraine
to stephen colkin or oliver stones
looking at different perspectives you
gain
a relative for me feeling like a sizable
number of people who really don't like
you yeah and say things about you
that
are
that may be cut deep for a reason i
don't understand why it's just
my own psychology what's also because
you can't defend yourself because
they're saying it and you're not there
and you you don't have any opportunity
for a rebuttal and if you do have a
rebuttal you're doing it publicly and
you're opening it up to the whole world
to chime in and there's a general
tendency that people have towards
negativity when they're interacting with
strangers online especially about
controversial subjects and even if it's
only ten percent of the people it's one
out of ten that's a lot that's a lot of
negativity when you're dealing with
thousands and thousands of tweets yeah
and i think
maybe i'm just a very self-critical
person but i hear their words and that
probably somewhere deep inside
see the truth and the criticism in some
aspect of the criticism and that's why
it hurts
well well it's but it's in one aspect of
you
right you know but when you're reading
it it's so
it it it's boiled down to this one thing
as if that one thing defines you totally
like if you've made a mistake if you've
said something that you shouldn't have
said or if you said something and you
know maybe you should have considered it
more carefully giving the gravity of the
situation
you know that that's just a part of
being a person and it's also part of
being a person where you're
communicating with things publicly in
real time thinking out loud which is
what we do
you know it's complex and most people
don't do it and you're gonna have these
you're gonna have genuine
hot takes where people just
see what you said and go why did he say
that [ __ ] him you know he doesn't know
anything about he doesn't live in
ukraine he you know there's like there's
there's people that are going to have
takes on that
in that way
and then there's also going to be these
disingenuous people who just use any
kind of controversial topic or subject
as an opportunity for them to get clicks
or views but that the number of those
people can be quite large quite large
and
so
going back to do you think it can
destroy a person because i kind of worry
about this and you're in many ways but
in this way an inspiration
that it didn't seem to have
destroyed you but except doing shows i
kept doing stand-up i ignored everything
i didn't read any of it it's so it is
possible to just a hundred percent yes
yeah
i ignored it all but you have i knew it
was there like your family didn't bring
it up my family was very aware of it my
wife was aware of what was the
conversation like if if your wife is
aware of it is there like a rule don't
bring it pretend it's not happening no
just like well i don't i tell her don't
ever read past the green beans
i don't
ever let her like read negative articles
to me you know i don't want him i don't
he care i go that's a person's opinion
you take a person's opinion you write it
down it doesn't give it any more
relevance like that person
you know could have had that opinion in
silence they could have had it with some
friends at dinner they don't like me
whatever i don't want to read it i don't
want to absorb it i don't even know them
especially if i'm not there and
especially if it's some
biased and
it's it's not an objective opinion of me
it's uh this
you know they have a narrative and they
want to stick to that narrative and they
want to write an article and they piece
it all together make you look like a
piece of [ __ ]
and that's their prerogative they're
completely allowed to do that but i
don't i shouldn't absorb that i
shouldn't take that in
you're not supposed to be taking in the
opinion of the world yeah you're
supposed to be taking in the opinion of
small groups of people that you
encounter so that you get an
understanding of how you
make them feel and then maybe you say to
yourself maybe i come across to rude or
maybe i come across uh too insensitive
or maybe maybe i could do better in this
way or that way that's how we sort of
shape our personalities and that's how
we we develop our social skills but
when the people don't know you and they
have this like distorted narrative of
you and you know there's [ __ ]
millions of people there's so many
people you can't peace
no actually i mean millions of people
that are like communicating about
something like during the height of the
you know the
attempt to cancel me or whatever that is
i don't know how many people were
involved in that people take this kind
of stuff seriously but the problem is
the uh false narratives take hold and
then you you have meetings you have
groups you have it builds on top of each
other and there's this outrage and then
it reaches you at some point
and
it can just have these destructive
effects and it doesn't
but it also
sometimes doesn't and in my case it
didn't
it didn't work
uh what lessons did you draw from that
mushrooms exercise my mushroom's an
exercise exercise is critical so i don't
think the mushrooms by themselves would
have worked but that's the thing that i
use for everything is the brutal
exercise like my exercise routines are
horrible
and because of that everything else is
easier i create my own [ __ ] and my
own [ __ ] is so much harder and it's
not just that it's also sauna and cold
plunge and these torture sessions they
in enduring those when you endure those
it makes enduring other things much
easier and it's also an understanding of
what's happening like you have to know
like media you have to understand like
what
the hot take you know youtube social
media podcast ecosphere
is doing like if they're talking about
you know lex friedman said this and we
have to comment on that and you know lex
gets cancelled in all capital letters on
a youtube clip and if you you watch that
you're [ __ ] crazy what are you doing
absorbing all this negativity it's not
good for you you are you you know you
and you know generally if you've made a
mistake and you know generally if people
are upset with you
you